[Music]
in Pizza stalker news hmm submitted by
it's still Christmas so it's not I wish
it was it feels like it's freaking cold
like the real winter right now yeah
there's snow on the mountain yeah in
Burbank yeah oh oh maybe I'll be the the
Burbank back now in the distance I know
I know this is in the mountains on on
Angeles Crest as possible in Burbank
mountains yeah you guys look down at us
no no not me not like down a but then
like cuz you know we're here
burbank's here you guys are here so
you're looking down at Burbank cuz I
look up really gets out that he's out
that me I look north suburban yeah I see
a man was arrested after stocking DMV
workers for months why because he hated
the DMV so much that's a pretty good
reason that's the only reason I would
stop him maybe he pretends to be a pizza
I would stock pizza pizzas Bob I
wouldn't stop PITA
okay no they go dude
he has Namath Timothy he's 34 years old
Timothy he was stalking Missouri DMV
employees for months by having pizzas
anonymously delivered to them wait so he
was giving him [ __ ] free pizza he's
losing here so this all started when he
was anonymously ordering pizzas for the
entire staff until one person asked him
to not buy her pizza anymore cuz she
felt uncomfortable with it and so then
he allegedly bought them for everyone in
the office except for her
Oh what she requested that yeah but
that's just the funny thing that police
had to add oh how do they find out it
was him if he was down on earth asleep
oh well because he was so obsessed with
that DMV office like he would always be
there walking around
and then even at one point he left a
large amount of cash on the DMV
countertop and then told the staffer go
get yourself a manicure pedicure this
guy's a terrible stalker
he's a sugar daddy stalker yeah just
wants to work at the DMV and he's trying
to prove himself well this is a like
look like one level up of creepy stalker
things so he was able to obtain one of
the victims cell phone numbers and then
he would send her Merry Christmas
text and other odd text messages and
then at one point a victim stated that
he drove past her twice oh she was
gassing her vehicle and so she felt and
safer on him oh yeah why they arrested
him when he was spotted driving the ER
that office because they already had
told him he can't come near in this
office anymore
what's his reasoning I want to know I
bet he's like hey mom I'll be back I'm
gonna go the DMV see my friends yeah I
mean yeah there's something not right
he's the guy that hangs out at the
barber shop all day and talks to
everybody and then goes home this is
Timothy do you know that guy he looks
like a normal dude in Vienna he looks
drunk that backstory I'm like a picture
tall 6-3 6-2 6-2 6-3 F he was charged
with stalking and harassment and he was
booked on a twenty thousand dollar bond
he just really want friends guy he
should have been charged with
hospitality
maybe yeah real goal in life was to be a
what do you call it the guys that the
DMV that do the driving [ __ ] tests
and [ __ ] oh yeah
driving no they're not an instructor but
they're the guy that the testers yeah
yeah he wants to make sure you could
[ __ ] park on a curb on the curb - on
the curb trick so he's like you
shouldn't have done that you didn't make
a full spy oh did he follow anyone home
or anything like that kind of because
that girl was gassing up oh that's
already outside of the dance this guy's
just a big fan of his local brands the
DMV yeah I don't know like if some guy
stopped by my workplace every day and
gave everyone pizzas I don't know if I
would consider that stalking but maybe
I'm missing something well he did also
forget someone's he followed them oh the
number thing is that sorry weird Merry
Christmas a little bit of I you know
privacy and you would be driving through
the parking lot all the time I mean
that's kind of weird
Oh rolling like he's keeping them safe
Garrity guard what if he feels bad for
these guys and this is his soup kitchen
so gotta go take care of the DB they
work so hard I feel so bad I mentioned
that he would come up with excuses to
visit this office for example asking for
duplicate titles you get parking tickets
on purpose and then like other vehicle
registration related papers and like he
would just get all these like I get the
Spanish forms please and also such an
odd obsession one that he liked there
and then he's like making up [ __ ] and
doing all these things cuz he want to
talk to that one person or whatever what
did he do that was illegal Oh her a
seeing-eye oh yeah because he was told
to stop coming and giving us pizza this
is the worst people whose spouses abuse
them and they can't get their spouse
arrested like they have to get
restraining orders they have to go
through all this protocol to to prove
that this person is harassing and
stalking them so it's interesting to me
maybe because the government institution
or something probably that's also like a
gray area right because now they're in a
relationship know that they might be
like what's yours versus mine where's
this one they have no relation or even
if you had a stalker but don't you like
if you had a stalker that wasn't a
relationship with you yeah you still
have to get like a restraining order and
like prove that you did certain things
something like they got that from him
and he wasn't supposed to be there and
then he was there but they just said hey
don't come around here do you mean
things but it's a government thing be
workers are horrible sugar babies they
weren't right and I'll back for money to
[ __ ] get your nails done and come on
man
know how like I would have been on his
dick already what I'm saying
following me home and stuff that that's
what I was like if these following these
people home and like actually stalking
then I would get alarmed but I mean if
he's doing it from a distant a cure'
number just to be like Merry Christmas
do something to these people so you're
in that that's creepy it's creepy but
it's like he's not like not threatening
the office pizzas come I want a pizza
right pizzas come oh and you're like oh
no this is weird
then he comes in with cash and then you
look at the cash like oh no this is
weird and then your fall nights up
things like America this is like girls
think like wait why are you being so
nice what do you what are you gonna want
yeah what everyone right girls well this
one for the first one was a girl was
getting it she's like hey stop so he
didn't go everyone was getting it and
she was like complain and then the other
one was here here's some money get your
nails then so it's still it's still
directed at if I was a girl and someone
bought the whole office pizza I'm like
this guy's bottom second this dick I'm
sucking his dick you're in a girl's body
with the mind with the mind of a dude so
yeah you're not even a fish girl nice
more like me me too me too bark you're
speaking the choir my friend you could
get a lot more for a dick so you selling
yourself short some girls you know they
get diamonds and like boats and stuff
like that but the cool thing is you
don't even gotta suck his dick if you
just wants to watch it doesn't say first
giving it away for two to little because
he's a ha I just want these already
giving you pizza you stupid you want to
commit no because you want to you want
to continue this lasting relationship so
now they give you the pizza you suck his
dick and he goes okay cool so you just
positively reinforce what he's doing now
big and you continue to do that so you
can have pizza every single one already
satisfied by you just making eye contact
and he would have given you all that
other [ __ ] well you know what good
relations you're a bad negotiator any
good relationship platonic or romantic
I've always been told it's like a
business ought to be 6040 you gotta give
more than what you give back to continue
it so if he only wants my eyesight I'm
gonna [ __ ] lick his butthole
Bart is over-deliver yes yeah he's a
giver he's a doll I bet brand deals love
you brand deals for free I did a brand
deal on coconuts Nellis free and condoms
and condom I did a Colombian deal I
don't get enough brand knows I do free
van is Amell very true they worked on me
I want to buy coconuts no big coconut is
too much they're taking over yes true
what what if he's like more of like a
bird watcher but he doesn't want to have
a pet bird so he just likes watching the
DMV people that's a creepy [ __ ]
stalker it's creepy but it's it's not
much yeah it's harmless stalker you can
go and visit I know she's fine what she
doesn't mind you go to a pizza coming to
my home you're treating everyone around
me equally so they're not singling me
out
don't tell Gio Merry Christmas everybody
he's a fanboy he did single people out
though because of the text messages and
then while she was getting her car
manicure
he was only able to get one text message
if you got everyone's cell phone you
could have texted everybody equally well
what about the manicure because if it's
the same person getting all of these in
that single out but if each person got
their own thing like you get a manicure
you get a Merry Christmas you get up he
wasn't like here for a nice shave here
you go for your barber for your next
haircut what custom tailoring it it's
like you need the nails you need
Christmas yeah
and he already was arrested on the nice
guys finish act finished last law we're
looking at this all wrong okay so if
there was a mega fan that loved their
sports team right
they'll have their favorites out of the
group so maybe you know in the DMV group
it's like oh you're the a checker and
then you're like the [ __ ] permit test
giver
like he likes different people catered
yes yeah he's like I like you for that
reason and uh yeah he's just a fan yeah
what's between a fan and a stalker not
very good their hungers follow you home
youngdo that he's we had fans that
knocked in our office door and we don't
[ __ ] show them like where we're
supposed to you know they're not
supposed to go there that's weird that's
very weird but it happens right and
they're the weird ones they're the ones
that you don't want those are the weird
ones and they usually smell like mold
why you smile so much more baby food cuz
I've been to playlist live you've been
to players live before yes cuz aren't
you going this year
yeah but Allah next weekend people can't
wait a lot of the different people
there's a certain type of people the
weird ones the fanny pack weird ones who
wear like the [ __ ] little ear ear
they have the head thing with the ears
on end and [ __ ] and they usually
smelling very dirty laundry very very
dirty laundry almost every time
[Music]
[Music]